[Music]
well good evening and welcome to Tucker
Carlson tonight today as you doubtless
heard during immigration talks President
Trump said something that almost every
single person in America actually agrees
with an awful lot of immigrants come to
this country from other places that
aren't very nice
those places are dangerous their journey
their corrupt in their poor and that's
the main reason those immigrants are
trying to come here and you would too if
you live there President Trump asked why
America doesn't receive more immigrants
from places you might want to visit on
vacation why are we getting more people
from Norway he said which by almost any
measure including the UN's measures is
the most developed and richest country
in the world while saying this Trump
used an expletive and that's not
surprising either since he uses them all
the time and was speaking privately and
yet for some reason virtually everyone
in Washington New York in LA considered
this a major major event why is that to
find out we're joined by Jose Parra he
was Latino communications director for
Barack Obama's 2012 campaign he joins us
in the studio say thanks coming up thank
you for the opportunity so I think it's
time eating of course you can have a
debate over what countries we ought to
admit immigrants from and I think we're
kind of having that debate but what
bothers me about the explosion this
afternoon is the dishonesty in it and
I'll just give you one example John
Walsh over unseen an analyst over there
was asked just a minute ago would you
rather live in Haiti or Norway and she
said with a straight face
I can't say now that's lying if we've
gotten a point where we all have to
pretend that every country is exactly as
nice as every other country then we're
being dishonest no it's basically
they're talking about I think the
outrage here is about the insult on the
exposition that is attached to the
people who come from these countries and
who are making a life here in the United
States contributing fully to the u.s.
right now they're talking specifically
about El Salvador and Haiti to countries
where TPS was recently revoked by the
Trump administration right and between
these countries we're talking about the
people from those countries they're
contributing close to a hundred and
seventy billion dollars in jail but I'm
not making a full contribution it's a
complicated picture but I I agree with
you if you're saying that a lot of
people come to those countries are good
people I of course I completely agree
but the idea that
not allowed to say that they're pretty
crummy countries Haiti for example or El
Salvador I've been in both of them
that's what people are leaving them to
come here so I don't understand what the
sin is you're not allowed to point out
that other countries aren't as good
places to live as America like what is
the prior Stephanie an issue here
because basically what's happening here
so that the president is connecting and
articulating the same vision that we saw
in Charlottesville when they're talking
about we won't replace you with the
chanters and the marchers we're talking
about slow down what happened what
happened because of whole masses that on
the Statue of Liberty that were trying
about in track with me here okay the
president from what we know and maybe he
said other things we don't know about
but we know he said these countries or
crummy places okay they're holes or
whatever used profanity but the people
who left those countries some of them
rode trains all way through Mexico are
hidden a wheel well of a plane to leave
they would agree with that
so why the outrage is it your have to
lie and pretend as Joan Walsh doesn't I
don't know I'd live in Norway or Haiti
like we've gotten to a place where
nobody could be honest about anything do
you see the promotion first of all one
of the things is that do we apply the
same the same metric to Eastern Europe
we're talking about countries that are
not doing too well right now in crime
measures and another issue but we see
yeah but we seem to be applying this
this only to countries where there are
brown people such as Haiti and Norway
like you said yesterday which again ties
back to this social r engineering that
hey that's a trying I don't want to get
a fax based on you but Norway is
according to the United well here here
are some the United Nations says if
Norway is the most developed country in
the world its sovereign wealth and I
think is the biggest in the world
because the oil discoveries offshore
there as you know it's the richest place
in the world ok
Haiti is the poorest place in the
hemisphere and has been for a long time
people are actually staying in this
country right now legally because Haiti
is so bad we don't think they should
have to return so if you say Norway is a
better place to live and Haney's kind of
a hole anyone who's been in those
countries or is Linfen would agree but
weren't jumping up and out all you can't
say that why
you say let me tell you something most
people in Norway according to most polls
do not want to live under Trump's
America right now that's because what
about values you know you are attaching
this label to people who come from
predominantly brown countries and that
is a problem is how decision on TPS are
being made now you know when you take
away legal status because if people were
contributing to this country then you
know are you using the prejudice racism
white supremacy fine but let's get back
to it so you're away Haiti I mean one is
the richest country in the world the
other is one of the poorest countries in
the world
you think it's immoral to point that out
it's a statement of values I'm asking
you a very simple question if Haiti
isn't such a bad place why don't we say
to the people who are here temporarily
in refuge from Haiti go back it's great
we don't say that because it's not great
actually it's everything the president
said it was not attack on Haitians it's
an acknowledgement that their country is
not as nice as other countries and if
you can't even say that out loud about
being called a racist by people like you
and the morons over on MSNBC [ __ ] call
you a [ __ ] I'm saying anybody who says
that's a racist statement should explain
how it is and you can't you said it's
like Charlottesville
how was it like Charlottesville look
we're talking about a predominantly
white country and we're talking about a
predominantly African country or people
or African descent and the option I mean
like what do you talk to president just
said a few weeks ago that everybody in
Haiti has AIDS and that's one of the
reasons why he wanted to cancel TPS even
though these people are here and they've
been vetted you know time and I don't
mean look you do know you know so I
actually know that when you're watching
all these labels to an entire population
of people that is problematic especially
coming from they don't actually look I'm
gonna speak for myself here when I say
again I think there are plenty of great
people from Haiti and a lot of people
who leave you know any do well I've met
a ton of Haitians or a lot in Miami and
a lot of them have done well but the
truth is that when people from poor
countries not a measure
of their moral stature but when you come
from a poor country you were likely more
much more likely to be poor when you're
here and there's a lot of poverty
already here in case you haven't driven
across the country and so there's a real
question about how much more we want to
come from organ class family by the way
so I dunno then then you can't look at
me and say that's racist so for example
I have the numbers on where our
immigrants come from last year we had
23,000 immigrants from El Salvador I'm
Sheryl grade people we had 404 from
Norway so we overwhelmingly give
advantage to very poor countries and
it's an honest question not a racial one
what effect does that have on the
poverty rate in this country I can tell
you that well this is a free-market
Network and I would imagine that you
follow the the basic loss of economics
when you have people creating demand and
when you have people paying into the tax
system like this 23,000 people from the
33 thousand number that you just
mentioned from our south from El
Salvador or the 200,000 who have TPS and
the status was just revoked by the
administration last week you are taking
that contribution away from the economy
and these people are going to Walmart
they're buying gas they're buy clothes
we asked you going to supermarket they
take away our stimulating local so
you're speaking of generalizations let's
and again I actually admire the
president also is to get a
generalization okay here's some
specifics these are the rates of welfare
use by country these are families that
are using at least one welfare program
the United States from Central and South
American immigrants that's 73 percent
can you tell me where that is Center for
Immigration Studies the people who had
keep the numbers on this and then from
South Asia a non-white region it's 17
percent they're going to see is coming
from the ten-ton Network I'm not saying
that people from South Asia are better
than from Central America I'm just
saying there's an economic cost in
bringing people over who are more likely
to go on public services and who are
poorer that's not a racial attack it's
an economic observation in a country
that it's a ton of poor people already
and you have no answer for that other
than oh it's Charlottesville well you're
talking about social arranging airing
the whole worry here and that's why they
want to do all with family based
migration
because finally made by a great
migration it it's what they consider is
leading to the Browning of America and
that's the whole issue that is your
fever dream I'm throwing some actual
economic statistics at you that you
can't answer and you're getting back to
the black brown white thing and I'm at I
just gave you I just gave you numbers on
the GOP impact from people from El
Salvador and from people from Haiti
right now if people from poor countries
are much more likely to go on welfare
and make less doesn't mean they're bad
people but it means the cost of having
them here is higher than people from
other regions I've seen other studies
that actually say that immigrants are no
more likely to go on welfare than I
would I would be to see that study
because it doesn't exist the rate
doesn't know it doesn't the rate of
American families on using at least one
welfare program is 30%
now that's higher than immigrants from
South Asia for example you're absolutely
right but the preponderance our
immigrants excuse me aren't coming from
South Asia they're coming from Latin
America and those rates are really high
and I think we have a right to ask
questions about that but you say it's
racist I can tell you something
have you heard of the five year bar I I
don't know what the five year bar is a
law that Congress passed that doesn't
allow an immigrant once they regularize
their status to access welfare so I
would like to know how is it that you're
coming up with those numbers it right
now prevents people reasonably well as
you're of course considering factoring
things such as when you get a
scholarship Medicare join you when you
get when you get a scholarship or or
public education you know and public
education is actually an investment into
the country so if you're considering
that if that's what your factory is
asking your question you know that's
really problematic right okay so about
half of all immigrants you can look up
the five-year bar and don't Library of
Congress but let me just speak to the
reality rather than the law the reales
reality by the way actually the law is
not reality I said if the law was
reality wouldn't be having this debate I
could tell you right now because I know
a lot of people who are not able able to
access Medicare about because another
five year bar about half of all
immigrants from El Salvador right now or
living at or near the poverty line again
doesn't mean they're bad people it's not
an attack on them but that's not true
for meant for immigrants from other
regions of the world again why is it
immoral for Americans to make the
calculation what makes us more
prosperous and what makes us most of the
people who are going to be living near
the poverty line or because usually
because they're undocumented and they
are not able to participate in the full
time economy the people who have been
regularize for a program like TPS you
know their studies by construction
associations around the country how they
have moved to
supervisory roles they're well-trained
and they're producing jobs for other
people there are and they are generating
concern well I know right now back of
students are contributing 280 billion to
the you don't actually know a lot about
these numbers and you're just yes I do
some talks oh yes I do but let me ask
you let me ask a theoretical question
then so we don't you know where that
comes from of fake numbers Cato
Institute anyone see Cato Institute at
force magazine which I'm sure you
consider that a leftist publication dude
okay let's get to a philosophical
question do you think it's fair for
American citizens who live here
to decide who comes on the basis of who
will potentially help our country more
in 1965 would change the laws in this
country more to be closer to family biz
migration because this is a more using
question well you think it's law as we
were using quotas that well if we're
using 88 to 1 1 3 much to stay in the
country about how many Americans are
looking for Marshall Plan that's on you
a rental regular as the status a dream
you can answer a question it is kind of
productive filibuster is it do you think
at least theoretically allowed for
Americans to say hold on me finish
uh-huh let's figure out who's most
likely to add to our economy who's most
likely to assimilate do you think it's
ok or is that racist like everything
else that I brought up is that okay to
ask that question or is immigrants
immigrants do and do assimilate as a
matter of fact you can tell your form
everyone's to ask that question what's
good for us are we allowed to ask that
question where's that racist who is we
when you say America is because right
now no 86 486 mile I don't know you have
so many who you define as Americans how
about the majority party electorate well
I can tell you that 86 a small that came
out today says that 8 80 percent of
Americans won dreamers to assimilate
including
to third republic so I'm so you're doing
apples and oranges and now you're
arguing about immigrants that is a does
a country have a right to decide who
comes in and who doesn't commit most
Americans want our immigration reform in
2031 average vote but every more because
you can't buy every poll and you guys
tack that in the House of
Representatives so it's not like you
guys want to fix the system I think our
viewers can determine where it coming
from Jose thank you thank you for your
time